Now, one of the cool things is,
you can actually measure the center
surroundedness of a ganglion
cell while it's working, okay.
I wouldn't recommend doing this to you
or to anybody else you have any care for
whatsoever, but basically,
the way you do recordings is here,
here's a schematic of a neuron.
So it has dendrites where they receive
inputs from the synapses, and when the,
the inputs are correct, they will
generate a spike, a firing down here,
and then these terminals impact the next
nerves that it's in contact with.
And if you were to put
an electrode right over here,
you would occasionally see these spikes.
And neural coding, we tend to refer
to as the more spikes per second
is a higher level, so we've gone
essentially from analog to digital.
Right?
In an analog system,
the amount of the voltage tells you
how high it is or how low it is.
In a digital system, there's something
discrete that tells us, okay, you know,
there's 15 ones and two zeroes,
that's a higher number than
all zeroes or, et cetera.
Well in, in the neural system,
the way we do is,
we look at how,
how often is the neuron firing.
And you can actually go ahead and
do this.
This is a picture of a a micropipette,
an electrode getting ready
to record from a neuron.
So you do these with neurons
that are still living, right?
This is why I said you wouldn't want to
do this to anybody you cared for,
all right?
And what you can do is,
you can then put different kinds of
stimuli at different locations in
the eye and see what happens, all right.
And if you do that,
you can find areas, so here we have,
when it's just black, this neuron
doesn't do things very much, okay?
But when it's white in the middle,
okay, and black out here, all right.
And, and what this is, oh, by the way,
this is time going this way.
So this is when the,
the spot was turned on.
You can see when it goes from the back,
this is called the background activity.
When it goes from the background,
when it turns on,
this thing starts firing crazy.
And then you turn it off and
it stops again.
Okay, fine.
But what's then cool is,
if I then turn on a really bright spot.
Okay?
Nothing happens.
It stays just like my background.
And in fact, if I want to
turn the cell off even more,
I turn on just the outside and
I make the middle black.
And here what you can see is,
it actually just shut down
the background altogether.
And then when I turn the thing off,
it wakes back up again and
then returns back to its normal.
So this is an on cell.
Okay.
That is, its center is positive.
Exact opposite cell here is negative.
Okay.
And both are found in the,
in the retina.
The other thing that's found in
the retina are ganglion cells whose
size in terms of their
response Is different.
So there are ones for very small,
for medium and larger.
And your system is actually tuned to
have more of a particular size, and
that tuning is what gives
you this phenomena.
So, again,
this is going to be a function of
how your monitor is calibrated.
All right.
But the, contrast sensitivity function,
so for me,
so what this is is, this is
a sinusoid where the frequency gets,
goes up this way, and contrast goes up
as you get further down, all right?
And the question is,
where can you see the bars?
And for me, I can see the bars
kind of like, oh, like that.
Okay.
So the question is,
why can't I see the stuff here, but
I can see the stuff there, for
the same level of contrast?
The answer is, my retina has more and
better tuned receptors at this size
frequency than at this size frequency.
This phenomena that you're seeing
is a function of what goes on
inside your eyeball.
And that can be graphed
out looking like this.
Two things interesting about this graph.
First is,
this is a function of frequency.
And, here they use
different luminance levels.
So they make it brighter and,
or brighter and,
it's sort of how sensitive you are.
And then something, and for the PETA
folks amongst you, please ignore this.
You'll notice that the human data and
the macaque, macaque is a type of
monkey, are very, very similar.
Now, this is done, of course, without
doing anything to anybody, right?
You just ask them what do you see,
et cetera.
But what this data show is that the
vision system, the retinal vision system
of the macaque monkey is really
quite similar to the human.
So if you were to do experiments on
primates measuring physiological things,
remember those electrodes,
we have reason to believe that what
we learn there is the same,
would apply also to the human system.
So, when you have psychophysical
experiments like this,
it shows you the similarity
between human and macaque.